ce week-end de canicule aquaboulevard
n'a pas fini de susciter la polémique
après des bassins sur bombay et une
hygiène qui laisse à désirer
plusieurs actes de violence ont été
constatées et même filmé ya l'album joly
directeur adjoint des opérations
dacquois boulevard explique que la
situation avait été dans l'ensemble
contrôler non non on n'a que très peu
d'incidents alors que des personnes non
pas du tout on n'a pas eu d'accident
aujourd'hui un autre témoignage vient
remettre en question la sécurité du parc
aquatique ce témoin c'est alan il
raconte avoir été agressée par plusieurs
agents de sécurité lors de sa visite
alors que s'est-il vraiment passé ce
week-end à aquaboulevard ce soir à
l'année sa maman s'exprime dans tpm fait
d'être là merci à m la maman d'alan
alors là on a changé le prénom d'alan ce
soir parce que voilà il n'a pas envie on
reconnaît ce soir et alan donc jeune
adolescent frappé par des agents de
sécurité au boulevard sachez que gilbert
des également toutes les infos de la
direction samedi dernier donc alan se
rompt avec sa famille aquaboulevard
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est
alors déjà je vous remercie de la parole
ce soir
bon si ça a été invité par sa tante à
l'aquaboulevard parce que c'était
l'anniversaire de son propre fils donc
ils étaient deux mamans monfils et son
cousin et un petit garçon de huit ans
donc déjà c'était une famille c'était
bien mais le contexte s'accordent donc
son cousin il à qui vous avez quel âge
il à l'huile à 15 ans ils sont prudents
à cousin à 14 ans d'accord donc ils sont
suivis de son pote voilà il soit là et
on va se retrouver il a invité comme
c'est avec cet anniversaire à lui a
proposé d'aider quelqu'un il a choisi
d'accord 2 vous y allez donc ils vont
vous êtes tranquille et que sa tante
voilà avec son co près que son pote
voilà voilà minuit s'amuser dans la
piscine à vagues où vous avez vu les
vidéos ou les uns y avait beaucoup
d'adolescents le jeune qui chantait
notamment
donc lui il était à ce moment là en
train de chanter au siège de rigoler les
jeunes voilà il s'amuse à paris c'était
bon enfant bien sûr et puis c'est vrai
que ça a commencé à dégénérer un petit
peu il ya des jeunes qui ont commencé à
lancer des brassards
alors justement on va voir il était en
train de s'amuser avec son cousin dans
le bassin vague tout le monde a crié des
jeunes ont lancé des brassards garder
c'est le moment on arrive à cette vidéo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc derrière bon là forcément les
images montrent qu'il ya une foule donc
ça doit faire tort oui bien sûr c'est la
direction dacquois boulevard qui a
accepté de faire rentrer autant de monde
et donc son personnel a été débordé
c'est un mois même s' quand je vois les
images mon fils il avait su n'y serais
pas allé alors eh ben on aura la réponse
des gaulois puisqu'on il a eu le patron
gilles voilà il a eu il a toutes les
infos dont ils vont
mettre ceux-ci maja les retraits des
finances à mon avis je vais être très
étonné alors dites-moi donc ensuite
qu'est ce qui se passe ensuite donc mon
6 et dans le bassin il s'amuse avec son
cousin alors les maîtres nageurs
éclaboussé ont fait appel à des agents
de sécurité
c'est ça moi là monfils n'éclabousse est
pas bon si ce n'est lancée pas de
brassard et ils ont pensé qu alan
faisait partie des éclaboussures voilà
c'est ça en fait il ya un jeune qui a un
bon enfant apparemment été avec la boue
c'est un maître nageur qui était à côté
mon fils à ce moment là et quand il
s'est retourné il a vu mon 6 sachant qu
est ce maître nageur était déjà en train
d'insulter de tous les maux les enfants
donc je pense qu'il avait perdu son sang
froid que je peux comprendre vu la
situation en même temps c'est la
direction il est nommé dans la situation
et je vais te [ __ ] ta mère fils depuis
d'autres comme ça ouais c'était pas si
parce que quand on dit que les enfants
là sont des racailles je me manquiez la
racaille en fait quand j'entends les les
propos qui ont été tenus ce don qui
s'est avancé vers mon fils en
l'insultant tous les nonces ont pas sur
la vidéo qui dit c'est pas moi c'est pas
moi c'est pas moi alors à lagny donc
voilà la wii ni la mairie y en a qui ont
des joueurs ne croient pas ils le
provoquent physiquement et coups de
poing va-t-il à elle me disait à peu
près la même chose ils m'insultent tous
les noms je dis c'est pas moi mais bon
il continue à m'insulter et laissera
proches de moi ont motivé le frapper du
coup vous dit tu vas faire quoi et lime
pouce du coulage de la rose et moi je
suis parti directement un peu on peut le
voir sur la vidéo est directement dès
que je suis parti tout le monde a
commencé à la rose et moi c'est parce
que je voulais bien sûr d'accord
d'accord et ensuite et ensuite il ya un
un homme client qui est venu voir mon
fils qui lui a dit fais attention à toi
parce que j'ai vu qu'ils emmenaient d
embarquer des jeunes donc là lui il a
pris peur il est parti il avait perdu
son cousin le temps de le retrouver sur
parti pour faire des toboggans ils ont
même pas eu le temps d'en faire un ils
étaient sur le pont il a été attrapé par
le bras par un maître nageur et ensuite
les agents de sécurité sont arrivées on
l'attrapé par le alors justement
regarder on va voir la situation se
calme alan donc repart faire des
toboggans et trois agents de sécurité le
récupère alors il le bouscule et le
traînent dans une salle on a une image
de votre fils qui est traîné dans la
piscine c'est très court un regard des
tricks me regarde
voilà encore ça c'est rien ça c'est
voilà le heureusement on n'a pas les
pierres on n'a pas les attend justement
je cherche des témoins donc alors c'est
qu'ils veulent bien mais d aider mon
fils parce que là c'est une magnifique
centre est pas ému oui je suis très émue
ben là c'est normal et il ya eu la nuit
on pense qu'à ça enfin c'est mon fils et
ma chère c'est mon sang je comprends
donc là ce qu'on lui a fait c'est
impardonnable si c'est pas une racaille
m'ont vit dans un village de dents de
scie de
rien justifier sa rivale à moi je
déteste le mot racaille parce que pour
moi c'est non mais pour moi les
racailles c'est plutôt le personnel
enfin je parle pas de tout le personnel
parce qu'on a des très bien y en a même
qui essayent de médée actuellement j'ai
des gens qui me contactent du personnel
qui essayent mai 2010 heureusement qu'il
y en a d y en a des bien donc après ils
reviennent vers lui wallace pas ce
qu'est ce qui se passe là bas il
m'attrape y en a un qui m'a tout seul
avec tu es tout seul non je suis avec
mon cousin d'accord et donc ils sont
combien ils sont à ce moment là je crois
qu'ils étaient 3 d'accord et ils font
corps avec t'attrape comment par le bras
oui il y en a un qui m'a attrapé par le
bras après un être de la sécurité qui
m'a prépare la gorge il m'a soulevé il
m'a jetée par terre après je me suis
débattu une traînée par les cheveux avec
un autre gars et ils m'ont ramené vers
une salle ils m'ont dit tu vas voir tu
va voir ce qu'on va te faire tout ça et
là vous commencez à me tirer et moi je
m'accrochais à la porte lorsque j'ai cru
que ça allait me frapper à mort il m'a
accroché à la porte on accueillir les
brèches créées dans tout ça et m'écouter
pas s en fout quoi tu disais j'ai 15 ans
j'étais ainsi j'ai rien fait tout ça
existe et ça et je me prenais des tartes
et il est nominé tard mario
beaucoup et c'est vraiment des indes est
vrai de vrai quoiqu'en pendant qu'ils
étaient au sol aussi aw aussi est il
moins ils m'ont amené vers la porte je
me suis tenu à l'apport je me souviens
les doigts en obtenant fort mais avait
même dame qui dit qui crée c'est pas lui
qui avait arrosé c'est pas lui mais bon
il écoutait pas ils ont fermé la porte
et là on tabasse et dans le vestiaire ce
qu'ils t'ont fait d'enlever siens bah
y'en a qui m'a étranglée et moi il me
gifler m'étouffer il a vomi quand même
on dira oui voilà c'était vraiment très
violent au point que dans le cuir
chevelu pour bien que ça ne se voit pas
je pense que c'est bien c'est pas la
première fois que c'est bien que le
disait quoi quand ils te taper mais en
fait vous les jeunes prometteurs et
déguster que c'était pas moi je me
prenais une vraie tarte du coup au final
j'ai dit c'était moi pour arrêter de me
faire frapper mais même là ils ont
continué à me frapper donc pour tous un
agent qui frappe et voilà on a fait un
surtout si frappé d'accord et qui la
quitte à frapper donc que ça dure
combien de temps ça va durer combien de
temps cette histoire l'a longtemps 50
min ou quoi cinquante minutes après il
avait pas de montre comme je dis parce
que c'est ce que les gendarmes nous ont
demandé aussi il était en maillot de
bain faut quand même remettre la
situation je pense que ça a duré 50
minutes c'est lui qui a
maintenant même trois minutes déjà c'est
tu n'as pas de notion du temps donc je
sais pas si ça qu'on n'a pas semblé une
éternité il a person et ont à un moment
il faut arrêter de te feras pays dont
ils n'ont pas essayé de discuter avec
toi de savoir ce côté c'est pas fait non
il faisait que ne me crée de ce genre je
pouvais pas parler sous j'ouvrais ma
bouche directement je m'en prenais une
donc là les trois agents donc ils sont
trois avec toi et ton cousin il est où
mon cousin va en fait quand ils m'ont
attrapé y en a qui après mon cousin par
la gorge il a dit si tu parles on emmène
avec lui du coup il est resté au même
endroit il a cherché il a cherché sa
mère surtout n'a eu pour la prévenir
aulas a mené mais alors vu le monde le
temps de retrouver sa mère comme elle
gardé un petit pour l'amener à la salle
et il a réussi à il a vu ou non avaient
été emmenés donc la ramener là sa mère
devant la porte alors ils les agents de
sécurité ne voulais pas la laisser
rentrer elle a dû faire un scandale avec
le monde pour qu'elle puisse rentrer et
enfin pouvoir protéger un mousse donc
elles elles rentrent alors dit quoi il
avait alors dit mais vous êtes une tous
les ans parce qu'il faut savoir qu'il ya
eu d'autres jeunes qui ont été amenées
pendant titre ap monfils qui ont été
aussi violente et et que quand elle est
rentrée avait cinq jeunes dont mon fils
et ils ont tous crié aidez nous aidez
nous il nous fera qui nous met des coups
de poing et bing donc la llc mis devant
mon fils est l agent de sécurité en
question qui qui le frappait et en
disant ici on est en france monsieur
vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas touché
les enfants ce que vous faites est là il
a dit il a bien mérité il a bien mérité
ce qu'il a fait c'est tout ce qu'il
mérite
il ya une femme de ménage aussi tu as
essayé d'aider mon fils
à sortir et ils ont pareil il a intimidé
monfils pour pas qu'il parle à la fin de
l'émission à la réponse d'accord vouloir
dans un instant mais juste eve vous
comment vous apprenez ça donc il rend il
rentre il rentre à tous à la maison il
vous appelle vous dise quoi c'est en
fait c'est mon fils mon conjoint qui m'a
appelé qu'est-ce qui venait d'être
appelé par part du coup la tente pour
prévenir ce qui s'était passé mon
conjoint a débarqué aquaboulevard hop le
plus vite qu'il a pu vu pour la victoire
voilà pour pour aider venir au secours
de mon fils et et demander des
explications mais alors donc il arrive
là bas ils demandent des explications
lui dit quoi ben il est tombé sur
l'agent de sécurité en question parce
que quand tu l'avais vu avant téléphone
et donc il a reconnu son accent
et du coup il ay l'huile il a devant
malheureux enfin bizarrement devant mon
conjoint qui est aussi grand et aussi
fort que lui parce qu'il faut savoir que
c'est des mecs bodybuildé d'un mètre 90
de m vous voyez mon fils il est grand
certes mais là que 15 il fait la moitié
de leur poids ils sont des bras comme ça
donc voilà je pourrais imaginer la
violence du truc est là devant mon
conjoint bizarrement il n'a pas mais ils
n'avaient rien fait rien du tout une
comprenais pas donc il a tout nié et
après donc il a demandé à voir la
direction et que la vue la direction du
pc sécurité qui s'est excusé et qui lui
a proposé d'offrir une place à mon fils
vaut mieux en rire et après le directeur
dacquois boulevard qui a dit qu' il y
avait la présomption d'innocence donc il
fallait comprendre que tant qu'il y
avait la présence en une instance il ne
pouvait pas agir et que oui on pouvait
aller porter plainte mais c'est tout ce
qui nous est mais voilà il sentait pas
trop concerne d'accord aujourd'hui
alan c'est un traumatisme énorme pour
toi bah ouais ouais je suis bloqué
depuis samedi que tu penses que ça oui
je n'arrête pas de penser à ça quand tu
dis tu dis quoi tu dis si si si c'est
quoi ce succès tu as du mal à dormir tu
j'ai un peu de mal à dormir
et puis il faut savoir que ben lui en
fait c'est pas lui qui a filmé les
scènes donc en fait il se voit sur les
réseaux sociaux
ça aussi ça rajoute aux traumatismes il
a quand même un un brevet dans une
semaine bien sûr vous imaginez la
condition pour réviser plus les douleurs
physiques parce qu'il a mal vu comment
ils m'ont tiré parce que vous avez pas
rentrer quand il le tire
le coup extelia non là je comprends
pourquoi il a mal aux seins à l'épaule
voilà
c'est ça la la la la il tirait bien sur
le coup les cheveux
voilà il va racheter cuir chevelu c'est
normal c'est la procédure
c'est sûr de
passer la procédure à part un assez
d'impôts c'est ce que met jamais
grâce à ça vous fait simplement porté
plainte et touba oui mais attention que
j'ai porté plainte ça fait quoi
j'espère que ça sera pas que salah ben
ça que je suis là aujourd'hui et merci
pour tout et les témoins qui ont été
violentés donc cette salle parce que
forcément c'est une salle du personnel
sans caméra et à la madame qui viennent
mais voilà ça je sais pas moi j'essaie
nous on a récupéré sa sueur délai vidéo
les réseaux sociaux on vous les envoyer
mais non on a reconnu monfils y ait des
amis parce que j'ai peur d'être happé
l'anneau d'or non sur cette vidéo là
c'est un autre regard oui dans la
dernière la bassée monfils exactement
après c'est mon fils non mais qui filme
non c'est non mais c'est déjà ça
alors je suis inquiet c'est juste juste
yoplait gilles verdez à la réponse de la
direction comme ça vous allez pouvoir
qu'est ce qui se passe alors déjà je
précise que j'ai sous les yeux vo de
plaintes qui fait six pages déposée à la
gendarmerie qui est très circonstancié
et donc il ya des points précis de la
plainte sur lesquels moi j'ai interrogé
la direction alors le premier point que
vous avez restituer ici c'est dès le
début la direction estime que dès le
début vous intervenez en balançant de
l'eau en provoquant un maître nageur qui
lui est dans le bassin en tentant de
protéger un enfant ça c'est ce que dit
la direction donc ça vous contestez oui
je conteste c'est vraiment pas ce que
j'ai fait il ya quelqu'un d'autre qui
l'arrosé et quand il se retourne il a
cru que c'était moi passons la bahia les
caméras aquaboulevard ils peuvent eux
peuvent voir et savent très bien ce
qu'ils savent très bien ce que de toute
façon il ya la vidéo début on voit mon
fils à côté du maître nageur et on voit
très bien qu'il ne fait rien ils disent
ensuite que septième fois s'il vous
sortent de l'eau c'est parce que vous
créez une embrouille et que donc ils
sont presque obligé de vous sortir de
l'eau là le restitue l'opposé la section
appliquer tout à l'heure ça vous êtes
d'accord avec ça vous une embrouille est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça on
n'écrit pas d'embrouillés est ce qu'il
pouvait savoir que la foule aurait
peut-être été choqué aussi delà du
comportement du maître nageur qui la
suivent 2 trillions bien coller sa tête
est le plus dans l'eau donc oui
peut-être que là mais lui pouvait pas
prévoir ça c'est parce qu'il prévoyait
faut arrêter c'est n'importe quoi et de
toute façon vous pouvez dire ce que vous
voulez c'est pas un ne fait d'armes osé
lui ces travaux avec une main de justice
il avait lui même sa signature
si je vous restitue le point de vue de
la direction ainsi pas le mien c'est
suite la direction moi mais je peux pas
rentrer je vous comprends tout à fait je
vous comprends tout à fait à l'ordre
ensuite monsieur vous expliquez que vous
êtes conduit dans une salle à part ça
c'est dans la plains enfants là où vous
êtes tabac c'est ce que dit la direction
tout simplement c'est qu'elle vous
emmène au vestiaire pour que vous vous
rhabiller et que là vous opposer une
résistance au fait d'être conduit au
vestiaire non pas du tout déjà ils m'ont
pris ils m'ont dit qu'ils occupent tu va
voir ce qu'on va te faire dans la salle
pouces oms qu'ils aient demandé que deux
qui m'ont dit ça c'est normal que je me
des bottes et là il a déjà il a peur et
déjà il est accompagné c'est un enfant
est ce qu'on lui a demandé quel âge tu
as et tu accompagnes et je veux te
sortir doit aquaboulevard parce que
j'estime que tu en agitateur je vais
aller voir la personne qui est qui qui
est là qui est responsable parce qu'il
est et dans ce cas là il sort avec la
personne qui l'accompagné elle n'était
même pas prévu vous trouvez ça normal
alors ce que dit la direction ensuite
c'est que donc il ya une discussion
entre la personne qui était avec vous en
quelque sorte qu'ils étaient
responsables de joux ce jour là à propos
de votre comportement est que les gens
qui sont avec vous qui vous accompagnent
ont vu votre comportement et s'excuse en
votre nom auprès de la sécurité pour
votre comportement et vos provocations
est-ce que ça c'est vrai non c'est faux
les personnes de votre famille qui
étaient là ne se sont pas excusés de
votre comportement mais non c'est
complètement faux mais je sais pas ce
que vous racontez à jeu je donne
exactement notamment en ayant qui
s'appelle au point de vue de la
direction ceux ci c'est le mal au mien
bat jeu c'est normal ce litige est
normal qu'il puisse réagir oui de toute
pas ça normal on m'avait dit que
normalement il y aurait pas de réaction
chroniqueur n'est ce pas je vais y a pas
de problème je réponds bah c'est pas la
mienne c'est le contenu de la direction
c'est pas la sienne mais monchy mais
attendez pas quand même mais y'a pas de
soucis on répond non c'est des mensonges
c'est des mensonges c'est normal comme
il ya une plainte qu'il puisse y avoir
une aucune confrontés sion avec le point
de vue de la direction oui mais bon
c'est pas la peine de prendre le ton de
[Applaudissements]
la pâte et non mais il appelle monsieur
travaille le mec l'année
mais remet tait pas qu'aux autres
joueurs non mais oui tu es là t'es pas
au départ comme ici à la même époque
n'est pas
bon les mecs là où deux secondes la
norme et ses fils n'étaient pas dit il
on rigole pas on n'est pas dans un rôle
elle chérit le garçon le petit il a eu
des idées il a été traumatisé voulu
parler comme s'ils étaient au tribunal
scénario qu à sabha si non mais tu vois
donc prend un temps normal on n'est pas
un mot n'est pas la barre la non mais je
te le dis moi jle excuse moi mais a pas
de voile a donc expliqué ce que dit la
direction mais c'est pas la peine de
prendre pas par point et lui dire
monsieur est ce que vous contestez ça on
n'est pas là où elle explique que ce que
vous avez voulu à la fin c'est
réintégrer le bassin tout simplement la
direction sait pas si c'est vrai ils lui
ont proposé de réintégrer le bressan
c'est vrai d'accord et donc bien entendu
la direction dit que s'il ya une
blessure constatée de la taxe parce que
ils sont pas du tout en hostilité par
rapport à la loi ils répondent
maintenant mais il passe à la télé ça va
mieux quoi série prenne tout à fait
sérieusement ce que vous avez dit il ne
m'a pas pris au téléphone il a quand
même contents ils parlaient ils étaient
sentais pas concerné je vous le dis je
vous dis la vérité s'il avait réagi je
leur ai dit par contre il a réagi le la
personne concernée n'y travaille plus là
vous savez que lui continue sa vie la
norme alors je vais vous dire je vais
d'ailleurs je connais je connaissais
mais la direction d'accor vous là elle
prend cette affaire très au sérieux
maintenant mais sachez le et le grand
patron d'aqoba malheureusement il
n'était pas là mais on salue remonter
cette affaire lui remonté il prend cette
affaire je vous le dis au sérieux il va
prendre je pense les sanctions
nécessaires c'est tout ce que je dois
fait vite et voilà il ya vu la plainte
déposée c'est quelqu'un voilà je vous
dis qui est un outil qui doit être comme
nous en ce soir choqués par ce qu'ils
voient ils paient voilà et nous on est
tous désolés par ce qui est arrivé alan
parce que je le vois là l'année c'est
vrai que voilà moi ça me fait de la
peine de le voir comme ça il voulait
faire un kiff avec son pote avec son
cousin il ya passé une journée
cauchemardesque maintenant ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'ils arrivent à vous arrivez à
passer à autre chose parce que allah ni
leïla un brevet a passé la c1 voilà
c'est un jeune homme de 15 ans voilà qui
a qui doit profiter aussi qui doit pas
voilà qui doit essayer de passer à autre
chose maintenant mon alan tu dois
essayer de passer à autre chose parce
que c'est vrai que voilà tata c'est
grave ce qui t'arrive et
maintenant tu dois pas changé pour
autant de ce que tu étais avant voilà tu
ne dois pas être traumatisé par ce qui
est arrivé et changer de comportement et
de venir et
je vais dire il faut que t'arrêtes d'y
penser voilà j'espère que la justice va
faire son travail j'espère qu'à qu'au
boulevard et la direction de
l'aquaboulevard va revenir vers vous
très vite si j'ai le grand patron
d'aqoba loi je me permettrai dû donner
vos coordonnées directement d'accord le
grand patron le big big boss voilà qui
est moi je veux quand même dire que moi
mon si je sais qu'il est brisé non mais
c'est vrai son enfance elle est terminée
voilà donc j'ai vraiment eu déjà je peux
pas laisser passer dessus mon sac je
suis là aujourd'hui ouais j'ai détesté
mais de 7,6 et puis là je suis là pour
mon fils parce que là c'est mes tripes
et moi je suis là pour le défendre je
vois là je déteste j'ai pas envie d'être
là mais je les fais prolongation et
j'espère que vraiment je vais avoir des
témoignages des enfants qui ont été
violentés dans cette salle aussi et que
mon fils fera la seule la justice sera
faite et que cet homme là sera puni
tu pourras pu recommencer aussi tout le
monde comprend le combat d'une maman qui
était en plus pas sur les lieux qui en
tant que son fils avait été violentée
qui voient des images
passées sur les réseaux sociaux qui voit
son fils qui est il a changé depuis oui
c'est ça ben là c'est mais même la
sortie de viva fait réaliser c'est
impossible est ressorti tout seul à
l'âne avec tes potes ou pas du tout pas
encore quoi t'as pas envie non sujet
mais après c'est pas un enfant qui
communique donc faut en plus donc ça
n'est pas
en tout cas moi je vous dis allah il
faut vraiment voilà que tu regarde
devant maintenant d'un super beau garçon
tu as 15 ans à un brevet il faut pas que
tu te prennent la tête avec ça c'est
vrai que ça a été un moment difficile il
faut maintenant que tu passe à autre
chose tu vives tavidado et ta maman et
tu vois peut-être la chance d'avoir une
maman qui est auprès de toi qui te lâche
pas et vraiment il faut que tu passe à
autre chose mon chéri et j'espère que
vous allez avoir des nouvelles dacquois
bouvard très prochainement en tout cas
je vais faire le maximum que celle pour
que ça c'est à faire avancer à l'âne là
on est là on ne lâche pas et on espère
que tu vas voir ton brevet quand même
hein c'est quand le brevet là c'est le
1er juin 1er juillet je serai la
jolie jolie ou à l'aube remis à lui j'ai
pas eu beaucoup de diplômés le brevet je
n'ai vu merci sève en tout cas d'abord
merci à vous merci à l'âne